bismillah hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Deen show this week we're going to
be talking about the verbatim Word of
God that's right the Quran you've read
every other book out there maybe you
don't even like to read all right so no
problem we're going to be verbally
giving you and visually some of the
different proofs out there that you can
see now okay it's going to become
something that you know what after we
talk about it you're going to start to
envision it and if you're sincere you
can be like you know what this stuff
that they're talking about this is not
no hocus pocus mumbo jumbo this stuff
makes sense you know and maybe you've
tuned in to some of the previous shows
or this is your first time and you're
going to hear many of the things that
just make good old common sense so don't
go nowhere
we'll be right back with some of the
evidences for this way of life that's
from the Creator that's calling you to
paradise and helping you avoid the
Hellfire it's a scary place that you
don't want to be we'll be right back
with more an ADIZ show it comes to you
the truth and the attribute of the one
who created you that he's one and alone
running this universe that he doesn't
become for he doesn't die he doesn't eat
and go to the bathroom this is not God
problem cares yeah it's this doesn't
make sense
who is Jesus worshiping this is recorded
in the Gospels despite all of the other
issues about the Gospels we put those
aside to say it's mentioned there that
Jesus worship God
that's from hunger Salam alaikum peace
be on him so now I love it I guess how
are you how are you able to say good
thank God how's everything with you a
lot of bang from the little bang now
we're getting into the program you know
on the Deen show we talk about serious
matters serious issues you know we have
people you know put the baseball
football you know the you know nighttime
daytime dramas that are out there a lot
of it's a waste of time okay
some good organic entertainment there's
nothing wrong with that but we should
have a balanced life we should know what
the purpose of life is not according to
our whims and desires you know we know
that look design in the case of designer
day you know we didn't make the Sun nor
did you know Bill Gates or any of the
presidents or any human being but
there's a crater who orchestrated this
and he's the one who should tell us how
to live our lives and and we need proof
so is it true that Islam is just not
about blind faith that you know we jump
into this music that you're mandated in
the Quran to contemplate the creation of
the universe it's a feature of the
believers and the opposite of it if you
look at surat al-mulk people in hellfire
are talking and saying well i'll kunana
smile on a little my own nephews have a
say if you really listened and
contemplate and try to comprehend what
was being said to us we would not be
here in Hellfire so using mind and
reason is one of the fundamentals of
Islam to realize the greatness of allah
subhanho town lots of Hanukkah in the
Koran says in mah ilaha min ibadiya LM a
lost when I knows that the most fearful
of him are the true knowledgeable
scholars because they know this cannot
be done this greatness and this glory
cannot be done by other than the
greatness of Allah so do we have that
problem you know we we got our brothers
in humanity you know that not yet
Muslims and you know others who you know
they believe in Jesus but somewhere they
took a wrong turn and they started
worshipping this mighty messenger who we
love no Muslim is a Muslim less he
believes in in Jesus we believe that
Jesus was a Muslim also cousin a mighty
prophet of islam because muslim is one
who submits to the will of god yes now
when you talk of them and you you know
go back and forth and you try to explain
to them that know where the Jesus ever
claim
was God and you talk about you know look
he prayed to God God can't die but you
say Jesus died so they get stuck and
it'll be like you know what
it's a mystery you just got to believe
you got to just have faith do we have
that problem where no no you have to
have faith but a loss of Hannah FATA
with his mercy upon us provide us with
eternal proofs evidence evidence
scientific evidence so objective
evidence so we come to this truth based
on evidence then we put our emotions and
we put all then they have the proof and
then within on top of that proof we have
the faith on allah subhanaw taala our
God that one mighty God Creator and then
we move on and the miracles of the Quran
being the last you know a prophet of God
is promised on them and you're not going
to have any other prophet as I said
their eternal evidence their logical
their scientific their objective it's
not like for example Moses peace be upon
him part of the writ see I have no doubt
that he did that because it's in the
Quran but if you were not witness in it
then it has to be the credibility of
whoever is telling you the story
a generation layer same thing with Jesus
right exactly we believe in those
miracles a deed absolutely because they
are in the Quran but we'll problem
homicide asylum his miracles were
physical he has many you know physical
miracles and also logical and scientific
miracles that without doubt if you have
a third-grade education you would know
that this has to be the prophet of God
and God exists and the Quran is the
verbatim word of God unaltered unchanged
in the same original language as it was
revealed to prophet Moses and well let's
not waste any time
talks a lot somebody's let's let's look
at one of the greatest miracles of the
Quran if you go to surah al-anbiya
it's the chapter of the prophets allah
subhanaw taala in verse 12 to 14
describes how the involvement of a human
embryo in a mother's womb he said that
we created a man from a nutfah
a piece a clot to maja Lana not Fatih a
laka and then we made it into and
listened to the wedding a piece of Chu
from Bahuguna
mother kata a laka and that piece of
true we made it into a leech like
organism and then out of that mudra we
created
and then we fleshed him with tissue very
specific descriptive stages of
involvement that was there 14 re-useable
tell the advent of electronic
microscopes people did not understand
what do you mean by a piece of Chu in on
before mother maybe something that we
ate in the stomach but why was it in the
womb of a mother and then when people
look to the electronic microscope sets
upon Allah and non-muslim people that
it's not like forced interpretation but
actually the Dean of embryology dr.
Keith Moore if you go on YouTube and
type Keith Moore Islam he would be
giving you that certification
descriptions of the human embryo in the
Quran cannot be based on scientific
knowledge in the seventh century this is
exactly pinpoint accurate description as
if you're looking through an electronic
microscope only Prophet Mohammed says
Ellen did not have an a tronic
microscope 1400 years ago only 60 years
ago people had it and why is it called
piece of shoe when you chew into
something what is the effect you're
going to have teeth marks what are these
teeth marks in the microscopic level
these teeth marks are that places where
your backbone started to branch out and
you're going to have a slide of that so
next to that not only that allah
subhanallah describes to us what the
next phase would look like but also
shows an example of showing us how it
would function light it would be
ourselves like a leech that latches into
the wall of the womb before mother to
suck nutrients out so not only it looks
like a leech but it actually functions
like a leech and then the bones are
created and then fleshed how would an
illiterate man 1,400 years ago
give us pinpoint accurate scientific
description that can only be seen into
electronic microscope 60 years ago dr.
Keith Moore said I have no doubt that
this is the career of man God revealing
that to Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
descriptions of the human embryo in the
Quran cannot be based on scientific
knowledge
in the seventh century the only
reasonable conclusion is that these
descriptions were revealed to Muhammad
from God
this is amazing so there's no way that a
human being could have known these
things it's nice it's virtually
impossible and that's why this is an
eternal this miracle a thousand years
from now would still be that miraculous
because at the end a thousand years then
promised I seldom had 1400 years
difference between the advent of the
first microscope and the wording of
Allah and he tells you it's not me I
reveal to you what God is revealing to
me I'm sure you've read a lot of books
is there any other book that is out
there that a makes the claim that look
this book is from the Creator okay and
describes the process of creation these
simple facts is there any book like that
anyway there is nothing like that but
actually some of the Islamophobes found
some Greek guy by the name of galleon
what galleon did is that get did fetuses
out of miscarriages and I sit him to see
what they look like and they claim that
this knowledge was with the Greeks and
Prophet Muhammad says I'm copied it but
when he listened to this true scientists
not the Islamophobes we tell you no
Prophet Muhammad is talking about
microscopic phases that can only be seen
by a microscope not just right he wasn't
claiming that he was God
no okay no he was just a guy who getting
you know miscarriage pieces of flesh and
dissecting him without knowing anything
about them and he never mentioned the
early microscopic faces the problem Isis
I will be back with more with these
facts not fiction here on the Dean show
did you say that you're not believe in
Jesus you have stepped outside of his
name you can not be a Muslim is
attending our faith to believe in and
love Jesus Christ by
he is the pretty why is it that when it
comes to one of the most important
decisions in life he literally abuse
ourselves it's not that the main thing
we're looking for is to see what type of
money he has so that he can treat my
daughter like a princess it's not about
back here on the Dean show and we're
giving evidences proofs people want
proof and we're giving them to them on
this episode of the Dean show that
indeed the Quran is a verbatim word of
God Almighty the creator of the heavens
and earth Muhammad peace be upon him is
the final Messenger of God and look I
just want to drive this point home real
quick you know there's a lot of books
written out there okay but I mean this
is just a small detail but it's major
because people say look all these
religions and they're making these
claims and then you know they'll just
put everything on hold but it's not
really hard if you want the truth you
don't have to dig too deep it's right
there I mean I just asked you a question
are there like thousands of books that
are like hey you know every other day
someone's printing one saying look I'm
the crater I'm your God and they have
these like you know facts like is like
we talked about this you of mark
scientific miracles there are there's
only one absolutely absolutely I hadn't
often like it in any other book you get
the point I'm trying to read absolutely
absolutely and why should we down and I
think some of the brothers out there who
are non Muslim or atheist sometimes they
get put off by manmade theologies and
say all religion is like because a big
mistake cousin because I mean let's talk
candidly you do have a book that we
respect you know has the Word of God in
it but it's been changed it's been
altered yes that's the Bible is that
right yes so is this why now you had you
know the drug people had that but then
what I asked him is that if you had a
bad experience with a doctor that
doesn't mean that we need to ban
medicine that we need to close down all
hospitals and all doctors because then
you'd be only hurting yourself keep an
open mind and listen and what we're
offering here is scientific objective
proofs
the second major one that I want to talk
about here is the creation of the
universe in 1925 you know the Big Bang
Theory came in that the entire universe
was one
and there was a huge explosion and out
of that massive explosion you know the
stars and the planets have happened the
Big Bang Theory
subhanAllah how would problem homicide
seldom if you look at the Quran in surah
al-anbiya the prophets chapter 21 when
he says didn't the disbeliever see that
heavens and earth were one enjoying body
and then we tore it apart
how would he possibly know how the
universe started billions of years ago
and as if that is not enough look at the
frontier project of NASA right now
they're looking for a sign of life on
Mars spending about probably close to a
billion dollars six hundred billion
dollars on it over going going one
trillion dollar what are they looking
for as a sign of life are they looking
for emails furniture you know they're
looking for water because you find water
you're going to find life the same verse
in certain MBA
chapter xxi that told us how the
universe started is telling us what is
the source of life in universe the
continuation of it and out of four we
have created every living thing
how would prof mom's I said I know that
and as if that is not enough you go to
Surat facility at 2:41 the scientists
would tell you that massive explosion
the stars and the planets did not come
out like that it was in the condition of
smoke huge slide tears areas of smoke
and then it got so intense inside that
the stars are born and the planets are
born fool Mustafa SMA over here Dohan
and then I lost my dad I settled to the
heavens when it was in a condition of
smoke and said to it and to earth come
they said we come willingly how would
anyone imagine that you know the hills
and the camels and the planet were smoke
but if it is the creator of heavens and
earth then and that has been revealed to
prophet Moses Elam then you know it and
then the third phase just recently
scientists discovered that that big
banks still happening that explosion the
edges of universe are still echoing and
expanding at the edges of the universe
in sort a very odd chapter 51 allah
subhanaw taala says osama a Vanina had a
Eden were in the moon
the skies the heavens we have created
with our own powers and we are expanding
them this is the credit our Creator 1400
years ago in the Koran and then Subhan
Allah the Quran is filled with it and as
we have more knowledge as technology
advances we discover these miracles that
people did not know just 100 years ago
for example in the beginning of the
chapter the Romans chapter 30 allah
subhanaw taala
revealed to problem Hamas I said oh man
he said it to the Muslims that you know
there was you know a continuous you know
when and loose battles between the
Romans and the Persians being the two
major powers he said that a holy battle
room the Aetna art the Romans will be
defeated the ethanol up in the lowest
point of earth and then within few years
within 10 years they would be victorious
again not only that the same thing
happened that the Persians defeated the
Romans first and then the Romans had a
major defeat over them but then with the
advent of satellites that place with
that battle satellites told us that it's
actually the lowest typographical point
on the face of the earth it's exactly
393 meters below the sea surface and the
location is there by route 90 in
Palestine today how would prefer Moses
Elam have knowledge that can only be
gained by satellites but it's not
promises if it does it's not me the
creator of the future of the past of
heavens and earth and history and then
the most knowledgeable of everything is
revealing it to me how would promised I
shall have no if he's not the prophet
philosopher know that there's no way
there's no other way around it and is he
is he asking for all your money is he
asking for you to kill yourselves till
you don't just lock yourself in a room
and you know abandon women not get
married is he asking to do something
burying that Islam asks of you is to
empower you to empower you empower you
either benefit you or protect you
there's nothing in the matter of fact
the cooling of prayers that you held so
many times we say what hi Alyce Allah
come to prayers and then haya ala fella
hi Alan Philippines
come to success and if you look at any
human being who follow the blueprint of
the Creator not Mohammed Mohammed Salim
is revealing to us then
The Blueprint sincerely he imparted
himself he became the most successful
human being that he could possibly be
living the most joyful satisfying
fulfilling life all the way on the
street path of God to the eternal utmost
success of paradise that's what Islam is
about that's amazing we're going to be
right back with more which with Imam
Mustapha Zaid talking about these
miracles facts not fiction here on the
Deen show we'll be right back
is the lady coming to the truth requires
two things that requires deep thinking
that you've already done but it requires
another step and that's courage if you
have the truth but you don't have
courage you won't stand up for the truth
and that's as good as standing up for
falsehood I would say this thing that
you just told me it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
back here in the Deen show and we're
giving some evidences and proofs we know
that the message is simple to understand
I mean that's something that's amazing
because if you look at many of the
man-made religions that are out there
you know they're just confusing esoteric
does it make sense you got to just you
know be someone who's got to do a lot of
mental gymnastics to make this whole
Trinity workout someone dying for your
sins
Islam is just you know for trans simple
it's easy it's the tool yeah worship the
Creator not the creation you know
prepare for the day of judgment
accountability you know the Hitler's of
the world they're going to be held
accountable they can get away with
things in this life you can have all the
money to pay off the politicians the
equipment the criminals getting away
would be a council but it makes sense
their judgment okay and this is one of
the beliefs paradise Hellfire so
continue on with some of these miracles
that you discuss and in the book the
prophecies of Muhammad we I mentioned
one of the greatest miracles of promise
I seldom a lot of people not aware of it
and I compared it to the one of the
greatest miracles of all time which is
Moses peace be upon moosa
alaih-is-salaam parting the Red Sea into
two gigantic mountains of forests
and drowning the Pharaoh the similar
miracle of mimosa cinema my challenge
out there is that there's no prophet of
God that had a miracle a physical
miracle the program system did not have
is that prophecy salem had supplicated
to allah subhanaw taala to God to split
the moon and now he tell me OMM now
you're talking about the superstitious
think what he means split the moon the
moon is right there how would the moon
split actually the moon was split and we
have NASA itself to be our witness in
doing that infidels came to problems a
settlement said we challenge you you
know if you do something for us and you
got do trust then we believe in you like
the infidels do all the time and the as
for something that is really ridiculous
so what do you want split the moon for
us he said that would take for you to
believe they said yes he came to prophet
Moses Allah after us you know afternoon
and supplicated a lot of hell that I
split the moon before Maghreb the people
witnessed the moon being split so wide
that an entire mountain of God appeared
in between what would they say oh you're
a magician you put a magic spell on our
eyes to see that way so a wise man said
you know what let's wait for people
coming from other places that were not
with us
so Mohammed could not put a spell on
their eyes and then we see what happens
and what the people came in I said yeah
that day on us that we see the moon
split and then it was put back together
now we have historical witnesses and
it's narrated and we have absolute
perfect historical evidence that it
happened but then how would I know that
these people made this up to just to
praise the Prophet or how would we know
a historical other historical evidence
from other countries that have the
similar night in Indian Scripture it's
talking about that Indian King that
actually seen the moon split because
they share the same night with Arabia
and he asked his seers what would that
mean he said they said in our old
scripture that would be a sign of a
coming of a great prophet so he said I
have to go and visit him he visited
Prophet Muhammad SAW Salem he accepted
Islam and gave from mother Salem a gift
of ginger the promo season distributed
to the companions and then he went back
sealing to his land but how then we have
the scientific evidence so panama in
1964 the first pictures that NASA took
of the moon showed this sign of the moon
being split with that schism that real
are I ll e around the moon all around
and they said that the samples that we
took from that area matches the inner
part of the moon not the surface of the
one that means that the moon was split
and put back together now Moses peace be
upon him parted the Red Sea nobody seen
him our life today but you can watch
that trace the evidence of the moon beam
split not with a picture that Mustafa's
I took go to nasa.gov and search for
moon real moon and then RI lle and
you're going to see there with your own
eyes and it's right there in the Quran
and so that a comma the moon thought
about is Sarah to one shackled homer the
hour has come near and the moon was
split this is amazing you know that God
Almighty the creator he didn't leave us
with our guidance he loves us and he
sent messengers to guide us and the
utmost sign of the mercy of God that
he's given you that proof I want us to
imagine this whatever loss of heart
Allah who gave us everything everything
that I have is given to me about lots of
Haddad for free and he said you know
what only your own try to find what
pleases me what angers me on your own
discover my straight path you'll find it
fine you win you don't find it I gave
you everything anyway
what would you say there were can you
say that too much you could not say boo
you gave you everything but because
allah subhanaw taala is merciful and
forgiving gives you the proofs with the
major prophets he give miracles to exile
except jesus peace be upon him o Moses
peace be upon him and Ibraheem a peace
be upon him and David and and and and
and Solomon peace be upon all of them to
show you that this is the one who speaks
for me if you want my guidance if you're
my ultimate prize he's the one to follow
and that's what America was for but with
that with promise on Salem the miracles
would have to be eternal and promises
and has these miracles we have those now
absolutely so tell us now we know that
we get to know the Creator by his
beautiful perfect names and attributes
he's the most loving he's the
most merciful he's not a man or a woman
he's nothing in creation but the creator
of creation and someone says you know
what look how can God be the Creator law
loving and merciful but why would he
have a Hellfire then how would you
answer is my answer that is very simple
when did you ever ask yourself why
there's an ocean when did you ask
yourself ever when you went out in the
morning how come the sun's scorching how
come there is a Sun you deal with it
because it is what it is so Allah Subhan
Allah Allah when we look at science the
fastest thing in the universe the
absolute standard inverse is the speed
of light light can spend planet Earth
14 times before it's one second imagine
how stresses are trying to wrap your
mind around it 14 times around planet
Earth
in less than one second the size of the
universe that God Allah Subhan Allah has
created light needs to travel from the
beginning to the end 13.8 billion years
with that unbelievable speed just to
reach the other side in that
unbelievable subhanAllah universe and
then when you look at our Sun and
there's a hundred million Suns like it
in our galaxy and there's a trillion
galaxies in that universe and then for
allah subhanallah de to create
Hellfire and create paradise and you say
how come that that happened it's there
it's one of the things that happen like
the billion blazing helium infernos of
stars all over the universe it is what
it is and the best thing that anyone can
do for you is to tell you how to avoid
that Sun burn how not to drown in that
ocean how not to fall into Hellfire
follow the advice or fall in the pit of
hellfire that's your choice and it's
simple or she is in greater not is
better don't worship Jesus yes
worse of what Jesus was worship who
jesus worship absolutely simple
absolutely simple don't worship the Sun
or the moon or anything that now was
created but the one who created
everything that's simple tell us we have
30 seconds left and to Allah we have way
more miracles and the book that lies
about Muhammad and shallow which I
advise everyone to give to their kids to
non-muslims that he want to talk about
but there's another miracle of prophesy
Salam which fast
my mom's Asylum said that the hour which
is the process of the end of time would
not happen till Arabia the land of the
Arabs would come back to be valleys and
rivers so holla for ages it's a harsh
one of the harshest desert the matter of
fact is a part of Arabia called a rubout
Holly The Empty Quarter that you know
even animals cannot survive there so how
is it that promised I said I'm saying
that it would not only come back to
become valleys and rivers but it was
valleys and rivers satellite technology
they took pictures and they look
underneath the ground there is a huge
network of rivers indicating that at the
Ice Age time Saudi Arabia and today's
the Arab peninsula was nothing but
valleys and lush green lands and rivers
so not only that happened but also the
changing in the weather and the melting
of the ice caps and the rise of rivers
at one point it would be covered again
with water and if anyone who played in
the sand you know if you have some water
running in a river like place and then
it gets dry and then you pour water on
it again what happened it would run
again in the same where it was running
before
how would promises all know that and we
have the satellite picture in the book
that proves it 1400 years ago now if
people want to get your book where can
you get it
Barnes and Noble amazon.com the
prophecies of Mohammed inshallah thank
you very much the cycle of eternity does
that be okay thank you cycle okay
animatic March and that was imam most of
as a get the book the prophecies of
prophet muhammad the last and final
messenger said to mankind
it'd be a shame if you didn't get to
know this man and this is how we
increase in our amman our faith by
looking at all the evidence by dwelling
into this ocean of knowledge islam is
something that stimulates your mind and
your heart and all of this helps you to
increase in love for your creator and
that's what you want to do you want to
love your creator by obeying him by
doing all the wonderful things that he's
told us to do and staying away from all
the things he's told us to stay away
from and following the best of
kind the best of example is a problem a
peace be upon him who called us to
nothing but good so get to know this man
Muhammad peace be upon him get the book
and this will help to increase you in
your Eman and then you can also share
this with your colleagues with your
friends with your neighbors because it's
incumbent on all of us to share the
message the message of peace with the
world peace acquired by submission to
the will of God it's now and we hope to
see you next time give us a call